[Music]
how do my nuts taste nice troske eat
scrub now get to the back of the bus
what the rest of the crew the
down it was a part of our scared
celebrate curriculum I won't be
partnering you up to raise a goddamn
baby what you mean raise a baby can't we
just go to Planned Parenthood
I got a coupon am I supposed to go
League if I got daddy responsibilities
oh shut the up I present to you the
top bot 3000 now for the next week you
got to pretend this robot is a
baby now it's time to pair
you bastards up milk you wish them all
man I gotta be booze with this worker hi
imma be cool cuz you're my boy sister
but I gotta tell it like it is ain't
doing Nathan I'm keeping it real like
Grover's dead that's fine as long as
we're together come on I'm putting you
with Modena ah damn Modena can allege
get some breathing room you like a meat
sweater don't get coy with me
we're together so you
better get used to me getting up beside
you Cindy I think it'd be good for you
to be paired up with Grover a word come
on coach you know Cindy and I belong
together
she's my lady nice try but
we've got our first game this week we
don't need you sticking your energy in
the wrong place so your partner is
ladontay
we progressive like a brandy
you gonna be my wife for life oh oh
[Music]